avec les annonces du premier ministre y
asseoir difficile pour chacun de rester
optimiste et de se projeter dans l'idée
d'un réveillon de noël simple et
paisible
une restriction de six adultes maximum
par foyer et des nombreuses zones
d'ombré qui existent pas facile de
garder le moral
aujourd'hui de nombreux français sont
perdus à moins de deux semaines de noël
de nombreuses questions restent en
suspens sur l'organisation d'abord
pourra-t-on se déplacer pour fêter noël
sera-t-il possible de fêter noël avec
toute sa famille ensuite des zones
d'ombré persistent sur les comportements
à adopter avec nos proches les plus
fragiles
sera-t-il utile de faire le test qu'aux
vide avant de faire des câlins à nos
grands parents enfin la seule et unique
vraie question qui obsède les français
noël va-t-il être remis en question
nous répondons à toutes vos questions
tout de suite sur le plateau de thé pmp
et nous sommes avec monsieur da silva
d'expliquer en marche hongroise merci
d'être là où on sort merci vous est venu
répondre à nos questions alors pourquoi
donc se déplacer pour fêter noël alors
on pourra évidemment se déplacer et on
déroge à la règle qui est une règle de
couvre-feu qu'on instaure à partir du 15
décembre donc un couvre feu de 20h à 6h
et pour noël évidemment parce que à fait
exceptionnel
on va prendre une dérogation
exceptionnelle le 24 décembre juste 24
décembre juste le couvre-feu mars que le
24 décembre on pourra aller se déplacer
en famille est-ce donc voilà on peut se
déplacer même dans toute la france
oui dans toute la france et ça c'est
vrai déjà à partir du 15 décembre c'est
qu'on lève effectivement les contraintes
mais on pourra se déplacer d'un
département à l'autre
après à noël on voit là c'est une fête
évidemment qu'on soit voilà chrétien ou
pas je dirais c'est la fête des enfants
c'est un moment exceptionnel pour
beaucoup de familles
c'est déjà difficile évidemment de
tenir dans cette période de confinement
avec tout
toutes ces contraintes est donc évident
qu'on va libérer pour que les gens
puissent se trouver au elles entreront
familles déplacées et on peut il y aura
pas de couvre-feu à noël donc vous
pourrez vous déplacer après 20h
pourra-t-on fêter noël avec toute sa
famille même si on a une immense famille
et plein de tram chômage a marqué alors
comment on fait monsieur le début non
non on ne pourra pas est rond et on ne
conseille pas évidemment et après il y
aura pas évidemment de policiers devant
chez vous pour contrôler si vous êtes
plus de six adultes parce que là je
dirais que la jauge on est parti sur six
adultes
donc ça ne compte pas les enfants de
moins de 12 ans vous l'avez rappelé tout
à l'heure d'accord et donc ça permet
quand même à une très large majorité de
familles en tout cas le premier cercle
familial de fêter noël et donc après
évidemment dans certains cas cela peut
évidemment limitées si on a plus de six
enfants je pense que là évidemment on
déroge à la règle par par nature ça
ouais donc donc ça risque une amende ou
pas ce nom on risque pas une âme en or à
ma maman de noël de non je ne pense pas
et je ne le souhaite pas non non c'est
pas le but satine moi j'avais une
question que c'est pourquoi les saisons
satiné c'est pourquoi les enfants de 12
ans pas pourquoi de 12 ans mais c'est
quoi qui change c'est un gosse de 13 ans
avait fort c'est quoi alors parce qu'on
considère effectivement que les
interactions sociales pour un enfant au
delà d'un certain âge sont sans doute
assimilés à des interactions qu'on peut
avoir entre adultes je dirais même que
bien au delà
parfois donc c'est vrai qu'à
l'adolescence on prend plus de risques
et donc cette jauge encore une fois
c'est une jauge est effectivement un
enfant qui sort pas qu'à 16 ans
évidemment ressent on aura sans doute
portera moins de risques à sa famille
que peut-être un enfant qui traînent
dans la rue et qui côtoie énormément de
personnes mais encore une fois on est
obligé d'établir des règles elles sont
parfois effectivement mal comprises mais
est ce qu'on pourra faire les courses de
noël est ce qu'on pourra faire les
courses de noël
oui bien sûr bat d'ores et déjà on peut
faire la seule chose heureusement
l'encadreur à ach à noël sera le
couvre-feu acteurs les magasins seront
donc fermés exact c'est exactement mais
on
on peut enfin les magasins d'ouvrir le
dimanche
et puisqu'on a dérogé à une règle qui
est normalement une fermeture dominicale
donc les magasins restent ouverts le
dimanche enfin pour pour les magasins
qui le souhaitent et qui le peuvent
faire un test permet-il de faire des
câlins à ses grands parents si on a tous
fait le test
alors alors si sir test est fait dans
les règles de l'art c'est à dire on va
dire une semaine avant et qu'on reste
confinée qu'on ne voit personne n'est
que ce test bien sûr est négatif dans
l'absolu on peut dire que oui mais il
n'y a pas de risque zéro
d'accord maintenant il est il est clair
que voilà on y est il est il et il est
assez il faut il faut prendre
extrêmement de précaution pour éviter
alors j'entends dire qu'on limite les
risques à partir de 24 48 heures
évidemment c'est c'est toujours mieux
mais il ya un risque quand même est-ce
que noël pourra-t-il être remis en
question est ce que si on voit vraiment
que les chiffres sont catastrophiques
est ce qu'on pourra annuler n'a
aujourd'hui on est trop près de la date
de noël qu'à se mettre en action
on pourra faire noël par contre si les
chiffres continuent et c'est le cas
puisqu'on est passé en une semaine de de
11000 qu'à treize mille qu'un an
l'information est tombée récemment donc
de 1000 cas de plus donc on voit bien
qu'il ya une reprise et ceux qui
disaient que le confinement des magasins
tout ça c'était ridicule on voit bien
que à partir du moment où on relâche
ça repart à la hausse donc il ya bien
une cause à effet et donc il va falloir
rester prudent et sans doute que si les
chiffres continuent d'augmenter
le signal qu'on envoie effectivement en
français c'est soyez prudents